Music
If there's something strange Sleeping in your bed Let me
tell you something If there's something weird Sleeping in
your bed Ow!
Let me tell you something Busting makes me feel good
Busting, busting, busting Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin
Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin
Bustin Bustin Bustin Let me tell you something.
Go!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Bustin, bustin, bustin, bustin, bustin, bustin, bustin,
bustin, bustin, bustin, bustin, makes me feel good.
Feel good.
Yeah, yeah.
Bustin, bustin, bustin, bustin, bustin, bustin, bustin,
bustin, bustin, bustin, bustin, bustin, bustin, bustin,
bustin, bustin, bustin, bustin.
Feel good, feel good, feel good, feel good, feel good, feel
good
Freaky ghost maid Freaky ghost man Freaky man baby Oh, ow,
oh, oh, oh!
If you're all alone, let me sleep in your bed
Let me tell you something Sleep and makes me feel good
I'm afraid of no sleep I'm afraid of no bed
An invisible bed Freaky ghost bed Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah Bustin' bustin' bustin' bustin' bustin' bustin'
Bustin, Bustin, Bustin, Bustin, Bustin, Bustin, Bustin,
Bustin, Bustin, Bustin Bustin Bustin, Bustin Bustin Bustin
Bustin, Bustin Bustin, Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin, Bustin
Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin, Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin,
Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin Bustin
Bustin Bustin Bustin B It's over.